graduating class of 2020 I want to share
with you today why I don't feel bad for
you the fact that you're graduating
during a pandemic and the protesting
taking place at the same time but before
I explain to you why that is I want to
give you a little bit of context on what
it means for you graduating in 2020 so
here's what it means 9/11 events that
happened to World Trade Center is a
historic event to you because you were
probably born in 2002 and this happened
in 9/11 2001 you don't know what it is
to go through 9/11 it's a historic event
evil number two myspace came out a no 3
which means you were a year old when
myspace came out I'm assuming you've
never used myspace which is probably a
good thing
YouTube you were three when YouTube came
out on Valentine's Day of 2005 the best
actress of the year was Halle Berry for
the movie monsters ball the best actor
was Denzel Washington from training day
and Sidney pottier which you may not
know who he is one of the greatest
actors of all time he got an honorary
award that year by Oscars Best Picture
was a beautiful mind with Russell Crowe
by Ron Howard MBA champions the Lakers
Oh too with Kobe Los Angeles Angels won
Major League World Series in 2002 lose
yourself to song by Eminem came out in
2002 and the reason why I'm sharing all
this stuff with you as for the following
reason why I don't feel bad for you look
if high school is the biggest high of
your life you're a failure I talked to a
lot of people and they tell me oh I miss
high school Oh back in the days in high
school it was so great because I was the
quarterback or I was the running back or
I was mr. everything where I was this
everything oh it was the greatest year
of my life
you don't want high school to be the
peak of your life you do not want that
pinnacle of your life because that means
you're a failure watch this there is a
show we watch which I'm sure you haven't
watched maybe you do with your parents
at one point reruns called married with
children
it ended in 97 we grew up watching this
because I graduated in 1996 there was a
character his name is Al Bundy all he
ever talked about
was the fact that he put four touchdowns
in a championship game in high school
and he was a shoe salesman and every
single time he always lived in the past
but in high school I was the man but in
high school I was this but in high
school I was there let me explain - well
how your life is getting started leave
in high school you will probably be able
to say there was never a more weirder
time in my life then my senior year when
I graduated this means anything that
happens in your life is better than
today which is a very good sign for you
that means the greatest years of your
life are ahead of you yes times are
weird yes times are strange yes times
are crazy yes you may not be able to go
to school and see your peers and hang
out with each other and graduating class
you can't go through it again and maybe
you're gonna need to do it on zoom' and
maybe it's gonna be little bit weird and
you know some of your friends are gonna
sit around they're gonna say you know I
gotta tell you man I feel bad because
look at us look what we're going through
other people didn't go through this
they had it for graduation you're gonna
have peers of yours that are gonna feel
like victims as if oh my gosh poor me
please feel sorry for me but I'm gonna
tell you something here you know what
else happened in 2002 you know I talked
to you about the song lose yourself you
know what the main lines aren't used to
you lose yourself Callie ryx here's what
it says look if you had one shot or one
opportunity to seize everything you ever
wanted in one moment would you capture
it or let it slip away you know what
he's saying hey you were born in Oh -
you're graduating in 2020 while
everybody is afraid right now you 2020
graduating class the ones that want to
be leaders you have a choice to do
nothing with these times of crisis or
you have a choice to be the leader of
the graduating class of 2020 so your
friends 5 10 15 20 years from now they
said let me tell you something man we
love high school I thought johnny was
gonna be successful
I thought Larry the football quarterback
was gonna be successful I thought Mary
was gonna be successful - 4.3 GPA girl
you know became successful whoo you you
took over and you made it count
so if you're graduating I salute you
because life looks amazing future looks
bright and if you got any other peers
that are like you hungry want to do
something big share this video with them
so they know our future are in your
hands and I'm excited about it
[Music]